paul krugman is a well-known economist
and he's also a columnist at the new
york times he's probably most famous for
saying that the internet will never have
more utility than that of a fax machine
well that was a wrong call and now paul
krugman he's back and he's saying that
he got the inflation call wrong we
should give him kudos for at least
admitting that he got it wrong in this
really long letter krugman goes ahead
and breaks down exactly what his thought
process was and why he missed it he sets
the stage by saying in early 2021 there
was an intense debate about the american
rescue plan and the 1.9 trillion dollars
that was going to be enacted by the new
democratic president and democratic
congress some people warned that the
package would be dangerously
inflationary others were fairly relaxed
he was on team relaxed and as it turned
out that was a very bad call krugerman
goes on to state that the whole
experience has been a lesson in humility
nobody will believe this but in the
aftermath of the 2008 crisis standard
economic models performed pretty well
and he simply was comfortable applying
those models in 2021 but what krugman
missed was that he should have realized
covet 19 created a new world and that
kind of extrapolation wasn't a safe bet
on one hand it's great to see economists
openly stating when they were wrong on
the other hand there's plenty of people
on the internet that want to hit them
over the head and say dude what are you
talking about this was the most obvious
thing in the world you can't expand the
money supply and have supply chain
disruptions like we had and not get high
inflationary pressures ultimately it
doesn't matter we can't go back and
change the past but what it does require
is that in the future when paul krugman
or other people like him go out and
state an opinion we should be skeptical
we should ask a lot of questions and we
should pressure test their thesis it'd
be great if they showed their work and
allowed for public discourse to go ahead
and poke holes in their theories at the
end of the day paul krugman he's just an
economist and a columnist that doesn't
mean that he has any sort of true
influence or power in the actual
american economy or in a position where
he can influence very specific policies
but because he is a participant in the
conversation he sits and can write at
the new york times and by many accords
he's considered a public intellectual
paul krugman can have an indirect
influence on many policies and that's
why we should be really really really
tough on these people and why they think
what they think paul krugman was wrong
he's saying it himself inflation's here
and now we have to ask ourselves what is
paul krugman and others advocating for
as the solution
should we actually take it on face value
or should we ask more critical questions
it's a critical thinking crisis in
america and it's about time that people
start to educate themselves start asking
tough questions and get to the bottom of
why is it that economists are so wrong
so often and yet we keep listening